was für ein wundervoller tag in
minecraft so schön mit der soll oder
rock band baba was war da und damit
herzlich willkommen meine lieben freunde
zu einer weiteren mord vorstellung und
zwar von der nc helikopter modifikation
sein name macht eigentlich gar keinen
sinn weil diese modifikation mehr dazu
hinzufügt zu minecraft als nur
helikopter wir haben hier beispielsweise
mal wenn wir in der suche ein bisschen
weiter nach unten scrollen
es gibt keinen extra menü dafür was hier
oben irgendwie angezeigten für diese
modifikation sondern wir müssen ein
bisschen runter scrollen da sehen wir
hier schon die ganzen sachen hinzugefügt
werden haben wir ganz ganz viele
helikopter dieser jetzt noch ein
bisschen verpackt den kann ich euch
nachher auch noch mal zeigen diese
ostbeverner aber der wirklich noch total
verbuggt dann haben wir hier das sind
alles helikopter die ich hier schon alle
aufgebaut habe und flugzeuge und alles
wir haben einen paris schuf wir haben
container wir haben greater graser tage
des designated von den ich nicht ganz
genau weiß was sie sollen
und wir haben sogar eine singer mit der
man rum schießen kann aber und da dies
länger munition ganz normal
aber ich möchte mich heute halt wie der
name der mod wirklich schon heißt auf
die helikopter und auf diese fahrzeuge
mehr oder weniger konzentrieren auf
diesen fuhrpark der hinzugefügt wird wir
sehen hier schon diese ganzen
verschiedenen dinge wir sehen hier den
kopf damit unterschiedlichsten designs
hier ja welche die noch nicht so
wirklich in die seiner mutter er so für
die nach geeigneten sind dann eher so
kleine helikopter und man kann wirklich
alle fliegen ich möchte heute nur den
wert auf zwei helikopter setzen weil ihr
seht schon dass hier sind alle
helikopter die hinzugefügt werden
wenn nicht alle davon zeigen würde wird
die materie wird total den rahmen
sprengen ich möchte nicht so lange mit
videos über machen
weil ihr das ganze relativ schnell auf
den punkt gebracht haben sollten wir
nicht selber testen wollte warum pack
ich sonst in downloadlink eine
beschreibung den hier finde ich auch
besonders cool das ist glaube ich der
british aero space harrier tue er hat
hier richtig viele waffen dran er sieht
richtig richtig gefährlich aus und ich
glaube bei dem kann man sogar das
cockpit hoch machen oder weil das bei
einem anderen nehme ich glaube einem
anderen kann man hier genau hier kann
man sogar das cockpit hoch packen da
seht ihr schon das cockpit des hoch wenn
ich mich da rein setzen würde
theoretisch dann kann ich ja manchmal
zeigen dass man passiert wenn ich mich
daran setzt also bleibt auf jeden fall
daran weil am ende werde ich die ganze
sache auf jeden fall noch testen also
ich halte euch die jetzt erst mal kurz
vorstellen am ende dann noch mal kurz
testen werden hier andere helikopter
dieser zum beispiel zwei rotorblätter
übereinander der jetzt auch sehr sehr
attraktiv finde ich den möchte ich euch
nachher vorstellen und diesen british
aero space harrier today gesehen hatten
wir haben hier noch ein helikopter und
hier der es also für die nacht geeignet
genauso wie der hier ein bisschen getan
der sieht auch schon sehr sehr ich sag
mal gefährlich aus mit diesem tag haben
verzug dingsbums und die items
hinzugefügt werden sind halt die grad
schon gesagt dieses ding aber darauf
möchte gar nicht so den wert legen weil
waffen werden wir gleich noch genug
sehen wir haben einen container den
können wir so ein bisschen nach oben
schieben sogar das ist einfach nur eine
kiste bier kann darauf zugreifen und
dann ist da so eine inventur drin genau
das gleiche ist auch wenn wir
beispielsweise mal irgendwann helikopter
reingehen müssen wir quasi nur so rein
laufen dann sind wir drin und dann
drücken wir einfach gleich wenn wir hier
irgendwie drehen sind moment wir sind
jetzt hier drin und dann können wir
einfach irgendwo mal ganz aufrecht ich
drück und irgendwann sind wir dann im
helikopter mühe drin da drinnen das pac
man noch ein bisschen rum jetzt sind wir
nämlich gerade hier drehen die ganzen
ort ist noch work in progress 1.654 wir
sind erstmal drin wir sind im pulver
motor seht ihr dass da hier steht hofer
ewering herz ist dieser glide mode also
bereits gleiten schweben und es geht
halt nur im helikopter bei einem chat
geht das halt nicht da kann man halt
nicht einfach mal so sagen ja ich möchte
einfach mal gleiten und einen gleitflug
haben so sieht das ganze menü erstmal
aus wir können eh drücken dann sind wir
natürlich im creative modus aber das
zeige ich euch dann beispielsweise
gleich wenn wir mal in diesem jahr sind
weil da noch ein richtiges inventar drin
was wir hier allerdings haben wir jetzt
beispielsweise mal space drücke seht ihr
schon das haupt weg und ich kann nach
oben steigen wenn ich jetzt einfach mal
wegen rückhalt kann jetzt nach oben
steigen wenn ich allerdings dann im
hubert bin und denke das ist eine gute
höhe einfach space drücke ich bin im
hort und bleibt auf dieser höhe in etwa
stehen dann kann jetzt beispielsweise
fünf druck damit das ganze besser sieht
und ein
v drücken man sieht schon was passiert
es kommen nämlich flairs das sind so
leuchtfeuer raketen oder so die machen
keinen schaden ihm wie ihr seht unter
mir sind ein paar tiere die werden davon
nicht bedroht irgendwie dass ich da
irgendwie verein setze ich kann das ist
glaube ich sogar noch mal machen
er braucht noch ein bisschen zeit und
das ganze werde da sind die flyers dann
gehe ich mal wieder zurück meine mini
also das war die flyers ihr seht jetzt
leer als so grau unterlegt dafür die im
moment jetzt wieder weiß was dann heißt
das ich flair wieder einsetzen kann
ich bin immer noch ein hort des players
wieder weiß ghana ist haar ist grau
unterlegt kann ich jetzt nicht machen
sondern ich kann die briten mit ge ihr
seht es links mit ge kann ich die waffe
zwischen ihr seht erstmal ganz grob
gesagt überall koordinaten links neben
diesem steuerkreuz
diese koordinaten von mir ganz allgemein
mit xyz da ich gerade im hofer mode bin
kann ich das ganz gut zeigen also die
koordinaten verändern sich die höhe
verändert sich gerade nicht die y höhe
die bleibt bei 7 80 456 so immer in etwa
weil ich halt im hofer mode bin also ich
bleib in etwa immer auf der gleichen
höhe
wenn ich allerdings wieder space drücke
ihr wisst es und einmal mehr drückte
beispielsweise dann steigt die höhe an
aber ich bleibe bei meinem vorwort und
uns und euch noch weiter zu zeigen
unten rechts seht ihr eine ganz leichte
einblendungen von den ganzen mops die
karte meiner nähe sind das verändert
sich natürlich wenn ich mich um blicke
dann sind die mobs einer anderen stelle
zeigt mir an wo eventuell feinde sind
ist ganz cool und ganz unten rechts seht
ihr 100 von 100 das ist mein leben das
geht runter wenn ich abgeschossen werde
eigentlich sind diese teile unverwundbar
mehr oder weniger ich bin damit voll
gegen den berg gerammt mit einem harry
und er hat nur zwei hp oder so verloren
als sie sind schon stabil sieht man auch
bei den kräftigen rezepten auf der
website
die werden da wirklich nahezu nur mit
eisen blöcken gebaut also die crafting
rezepte möchte ich nicht zeigen wollte
auch oft kritisiert dass die gezeigte
weil die man sich selber nach gucken
kann die volturi view sehen und unten
links ganz normale norden süden westen
osten die uhrzeit und dass ich gerade
diese waffe da unten das ist seine
munition packen dingsbums und ja ich
denke die anderen
maaßen erklären sich so in etwa
eigentlich von alleine und ich würde
sagen wir kommen jetzt einfach mal zu
den waffen und zwar seht ihr schon unten
rechts und links m 230 10 15 15 wenn ich
einmal rechts rücke das nur noch 14 15
mit g kann ich diese ganzen sachen
wechseln und ich gehe einfach mal den
ds5 modus setzt ich bin ein talent ich
bin einfach ausgestiegen
okay aber davon waren uns natürlich
nicht beirren lassen wir gehen natürlich
direkt wieder rein in den helikopter
wenn ich da überhaupt noch mal ja aber
nicht okay supersache oberhofer
motorhaube oberhofer bleibt okay ich hab
mir wieder ein bisschen unter kontrolle
so wir sind jetzt nämlich gerade bei der
m 230 chain gang
jetzt kann ich einfach mal rechtsweg
drücken und kann nun schießen ich gehe
mal ein stückchen nach unten so einmal
hier wieder wir wissen natürlich wenn
wir nach unten gehen wollen aus dem
hofer mode raus so wir sanft mal wieder
so tag auf dieser höhe möchte ich gern
im hof bleiben genau und ihr seht ihr
hier schon so ich hoffe mal dass dass
man die sensation gegen die erkennen
kann
ja aber ich denke ihr hört auf jeden
fall und wenn mops vor mir wären wohl
gar keine sind treffen da hinten
ich glaube ich bin ein bisschen höher
als die aber ich kann auf jeden fall
schießen allerdings gibt es natürlich
auch noch andere sachen wie
beispielsweise wieder rücken mal geht
und jetzt die snb rocket wir können so
machen sie das mal lieber in den berg
hinein damit ihr das seht ihr seht schon
dass es ein bisschen wie tnt nicht ganz
so toll aber wir können auf jeden fall
ein paar raketen schießen und so
theoretisch mal so einen ganzen berg
kaputt machen dann wenn ich wieder fünf
druck gerät hier unten 0 von 22 butt
gerade nachgeladen ich kann wieder gehe
drücken dann haben wir beispielsweise
eines dinge kann ich auch mal raus hauen
kommt schon länger komitee hallo lilli
gerade keine sting abschied sondern muss
ich dafür höher sein
heute sind jedenfalls ist die dinger
halt in etwa auch so was ähnliches wie
diese rocket es hat nur noch mal noch
stärker okay ist immer wieder wirklich
nicht abschießen
beinahe wäre noch dass hellfire da
können wir auch einfach rechts gedrückt
lassen dann schießt er hier rum und hier
das ganz normal hält
das tv wo dann aber wirklich noch feuer
mit raus kommen damit man irgendwie
gegen den baum schießen zeige ich euch
mal hinten dann fängt der ganze jetzt
habe ich durch den baum durch geschossen
ich schieß mal da unten hin wenn ich das
in etwa hinkriege mann ich will gegen
den baum schließen dass mich gegen den
baum schießen kommen kommen kommt ja nee
jetzt kommen jetzt jetzt aber gegen den
bau mit der müsste wirklich gegen den
bands gehen ja und der ganze baum ist
einfach weg ist auf jeden fall richtig
hier wird er wieder die chain gang und
das würde ich sagen fast alle erst mal
von diesem helikopter
das war den ich euch gerade gezeigt habe
dass war war das überhaupt ich bin
gleich anfangen dann eingestiegen
okay das ist das was hier sogar schon
dran steht die bakonyi also ihr seht
schon dass thailand nicht meine textur
das ist aber so ein riesen flaggschiff
ist auf jeden fall auch richtig neues da
hinten in mahlberg hängt auch noch
irgendwann ding drin das habe ich da
rein gerammt war ich ein bisschen wirr
und ja dann habe ich noch den british
aero space harrier den setzt hier
einfach mal hin und das ist wirklich mal
in mein allerliebstes ihr seht schon
dass das cockpit das geht hoch
wir springen hier wieder rein ganz
normal mit space und drücken jetzt
einfach rechtsklick also mal drin an ihr
seht das cockpit schließt sich das
wollte ich euch nun auch schon zeigen
und hier sieht das ganze viel
futuristische aus an sich sind die
ganzen steuerungselemente erst mal
gleich aber ich finde ich finde diesen
jet hat immer noch cool aber mit dem
halt wirklich man fühlt sich so wirklich
aggressiv zum helikopter sondern kleine
[ __ ] teil irgendwie jedenfalls ihr
seht schon hier mit f kann ich hier in
den videomodus gehen und mit einem fall
wieder normale den normalmodus ich bleib
allerdings wie beim normalen modus nicht
so cool finde mit v
ein flair ja ihr habt es glaube ich
gehör das hirn flair kam so dann sehen
wir hier wieder den kameraden hab ich
glaube ich wurden gar nicht gezeigt weil
sie mir liegt ob da glaube ich auch
gerade gar nicht gab und zwar kann ich
mal times 20.000 machen dann ist es hier
nämlich nacht und dann kann ich zähle
drückt und dann bin ich im nachtaktiv
monaten sehe ich das ganze relativ cool
ich stoppe lassen
das ist ganz cool aus ganz normal wieder
jetzt weg gedrückt halten und wir sind
in einer kuhle dass es cool
wir können aber nach oben gucken ganz
einfach und dann fliegen wir nämlich
schon rum und jetzt sind wir mal auf
dieser höhe
und jetzt können wir das teil bisschen
stolz sind über den wolken es gibt
keinen hoc modus weil ich mach das mal
hier ganz aus es gibt ich mache das auch
mal ganz groß oft hätten 0
damit bin ich ganz dieses diese kurve
grüne linsen haben es gibt kein hofer
modus war wie schon gesagt wir sind in
dem jet
da gibt es halt so was nicht aber wir
haben wieder coole waffen ich kann hier
nur die gau zum beispiel einsatz im
kongo kommt schnell nach oben noch um
nach oben nach oben
aber ihr seht auch gerade schon ich habe
hier wieder den boden gerammt und unten
die hälfte ist man auch auf 100 also die
teile sind echt massiv was das ganze
angeht wie wechsele man eben auf die chc
rv 7 rocket und schießbude und
helikopter ab ok werden jetzt noch nicht
kaputt gemacht dass jetzt nämlich mein
ziel dass ich noch einmal so ein
helikopter mal eben kaputt mache und ihr
seht schon wenn ich dir so drin sitzen
das sieht schon cool aus das ist schon
cool das fliegen wir hier mal rum ich
gehe mal wieder hier rein und wo haben
wir den helikopter da man
wieso die asse schon die teile sind
richtig richtig krank er hat gerade auch
schon wieder 04 11 verloren weil ich
davon in den tiefflug gegangen
wir wechseln aber mal wieder die waffe
auf einen erneuen sidewinder was das
denn nochmal okay dann kann ich gar
nicht abschießen kommen grünen nicht
gebaut aber zum glück nur 211 verläuft
so kommen jetzt jetzt hier hin hin hin
hin
das war ein bisschen zu spät glaube ich
aber ihr seht glaube ich schon dass
diese attacke macht die macht nämlich
sondern einfach ihr seht da hinten noch
immer das brennen das teil macht einfach
dass das unseren brennender strahl vom
himmel kommt was das seine fahrt fort
und bog dann nehmen wir zwei mal ganz
kurz getroffen
hallo die teile sind echte unverwundbar
guckt man alles um die herum es
irgendwie zerstört ich werde jetzt mal
eben wieder
deswegen nehmen und schied nach vorne
hin
du sollst dahin schießen auf diesen
helikopter den möchte ich abschließend
hofburg profitiert wie kommen wir jetzt
mal diese rocket den da möchte ich
abschließend den hier denen ihr den
genen den kollegen hier und den treffe
ich gar nicht oder die teile sind echt
also ich hab schon hingekriegt dass ich
einen helikopter zerstört habe das wird
aber das war nur ein kleines teil und
ich denke einfach dass die hier einfach
viel viel statt da ist als verschrottet
worden da war der kleine der kleine
helikopter sondern alle miteinander
zerstört werden bei dem jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen schneller
ich denke jedenfalls erst mal dass ich
euch die groben sachen der modifikation
gezeigt habe
gebt mal daumen hoch wenn ihr bock hätte
das irgendwann eventuell song let's play
together mit dieser modifikation kommen
würde
das wird mich auf jeden fall freuen wenn
ihnen mag ich und mag ich da lass ich
weiß schon was da in zukunft kommen
ich wünsche ihm viel sagen schreib mir
weitere modifikation die kommentare da
sehen wir uns bei einer nächsten mord
vorstellung wieder